permission for this protest had been
refused but with thousands of
demonstrators arriving in the town of
Tai Po near the border with mainland
China there was no way they were going
to be stopped
it's part of the strategy to gain more
support for the campaign against the
government's now dead extradition bill
protesters are angry that the bill has
not been formally withdrawn they say
China is trying to gradually erode Hong
Kong's freedoms a number of stores in
the town had closed
fearing the same kind of violence that
has marred the ends of otherwise
peaceful protests but some stayed open
to offer free drinks and snacks to the
protesters as the March ended several
thousand protesters advanced on the
town's police station where they came up
against a cordon of police thousands of
protesters have made it this far and it
built this barricade the police line is
just another hundred meters further on
there was a standoff everybody was
expecting that there would be some sort
of clash but then words suddenly went
out amongst the protesters that they
were pulling back and adjust as soon as
they arrived here they have now fallen
away it's all part of this movements
hit-and-run tactics designed to have the
biggest impact across Hong Kong
splitting up into smaller groups some
protesters went to shopping districts
others blocked roads and intersections
like this one in chart in another town
that has seen violence with police
protesters hastily assembled barricades
to block the traffic before police
arrived to drive them off the protesters
scatter to cause disruption elsewhere as
this weekend of civil disobedience drags
on Rob McBride al Jazeera Hong Kong